hallo mein name ist lucanet ich
willkommen zu einer folge pokémon titel
lese und pokemon unzensiert deswegen
spielen wir pokemon an sensoren edition
die grafik ist extrem scheiße das tut
mir leid das kann ich aber auch nichts
für das ist halt einfach kacke ja wir
machen mal einfach ein neues game
pokémon fan game makers award des wortes
super gemacht hast du das hello kitty
waiting work ethic die scheiße ich habe
keine ahnung wie offentlich das ganze
sagen muss diese ganze scheiße immer und
wieder meinen namen kennt meinen armen
leute nennen mich den pokémon professor
frag mich für hilfe oder halt die fresse
ich brauche keine info und das ist diese
welt ist inhabitat heißt bewohnt oder
menschen und pokémon leben zusammen in
dem sie sich gegenseitig unterstützten
einige menschen spielen mit pokemon
eingesehen sehen what msd bietet aber
okay andere schauen ihm zu wehren sie
sich gegenseitig töten total brutal
eigentlich jetzt gibt außerdem einige
pokémon bezogene mysterien die man lösen
muss aber tiger unterbach setzen
aber es juckt mich redest du ein junge
oder mädchen ich bin eine junge also wie
alt bin ich ich ich sag mir wieder ein
gescheiter name ist okay jetzt klick ich
zum aufruf zu drücken und er sagt also
du bist luca ja ich bin luca luka weißt
du was du siehst dass hennig ich
versuche so gut wie möglich
schnellstmöglich zu übersetzen wäre ich
zocke und per celik heißt erbärmlich
[ __ ] you hate you ich meine augenfarbe
ist genauso wie die farbe von diesem
pulli den lichern hab das fällt mir
jetzt gerade erst auf facebook chat ich
bin grad mittel eine aufnahme aber meine
augenfarbe ist genau die gleiche wie von
diesem politkrimi hättet mich aufs netz
ich heiße dort laser luca
wenn ihr das video seht bin ich
wahrscheinlich fünf tage später in new
york und in erle und dann werde ich viel
schleppen wie ich an den strand pinkel
und du siehst erbärmlich aus also sagen
wir mal ich habe das richtige ding für
babys wie dich es nennt sich easy mode
den bräuchte ich glaube ich wirklich
fein okay dann luca bist du bereit deine
behinderte story beginnt sich dabei zu
entfalten also bitte halt die fresse ich
bin hier in meiner bude und kann jetzt
kann ich mich irgendwie ins bett legen
oder so ich will am liebsten einfach ich
kann nicht da lang laufen hier steht
irgendeinem blog was ein scheiß ich kann
da einfach nicht lang
hier kann ich auch nicht lange wir haben
wir einige bücher ist die burg chef olaf
bock super pokémon der jsg mal an den pc
und motto über 13 teams deutscher liegt
doch in die pause was soll ich denn die
posten ich hab doch noch gar nicht habe
mir jetzt einfach mal die puschen daraus
genommen
exeter jetzt den pc turnover und jetzt
gehe ich mal einfach zu meiner mutter
hey mama was seh ich kann vielleicht
hallo süße professor auf will ich sehen
ich hab gehört denn überreichen für dich
dann gehen wir doch jetzt an
er kann einfach über die studie darüber
laufen wir gehen einfach mal zu
professor gespräche jetzt mal mit ihm
ihr ich bin sehr faul ich stehe hier die
ganze zeit weißt du eigentlich warte ich
hier die ganze zeit und habe vergessen
wo man zu hause ist
wir gehen mal zu professor auch in seine
bude und da ist professor ich wusste so
verdammt lange warten aber ich denke mal
einfach auf mein und er antwortete
wasting time stamp okimo ich nehme ja
luca obtain bombe soll ein paar sekunden
später praktisch ist das war nicht die
jetzt habe ich wieder sagen wisst ihr
was fakt ist schert nicht immer wieder
sagen jetzt einfach schick jetzt habe
ich eine schicki discos oft hesse bild
in map okay ich habe jetzt einen pokédex
bekommen also jetzt verfügt doch mal
gehe hier raus und startet ein
bescheuertes abenteuer danke professor
luc ackermann damian green tech days of
disco pigs match stronger than yours
heißt dein maul meins meins ist ich hab'
ich hab auch ich habe also nicht die
also bisasam bringschuld
ich kann ja anscheinend irgendwie den
namen von ihm weg machen aber hier ist
einfach kein knopf um das wegzumachen
ich soll das denn jetzt gehen ich würde
den vorgängern wachsenden weil er in
vier tagen auf eine maus merchandise
rauskommt da ist ein link glaube ich
irgendwo eine beschreibung aber ich
denke jetzt einfach mal gary klick auf
ok ja gary das ist toll an gerry the
fucking roms luca ok wo kann ich jetzt
okay ich kann gehen auch jetzt kommt der
spaß noch anhält
heard of traders hat ja habe ich schon
gehört ja jetzt lasst mich doch endlich
mal raus gehen hier road to hollywood
darling einfach ganz viele schlafende
männer im weg da kann ich die
ansprechenden blatt bullocks lucky
strike ich gehe jetzt mal einfach hier
raus und auf die route 1 und dann ist
hier auch direkt kommen doggystyle ich
laufe einfach mal hier durchs gras und
zu schauen ob ich irgendwo hingehe hier
weiter hoch und dann sind in foxi ass
déi ich will einfach mal kämpfen zum
ende des videos luca verloren poschen ja
okay das ist das ist cool aber ich will
einfach mal hier ein bisschen kämpfen
und ich meine das muss unser erster
kampf und es kommt ein
dieser sah mich macht ecke das ist
schiri ist ecke und dann haben wir ihnen
auch schon noch die hälfte und hermann
häckl und ich mag norbert ecke und dann
hat er wir haben erwärmen das war's dann
irgendwie gegen den trainer kämpfen oder
stimmt er steht eigentlich nur um uns
den leuten zu sagen gibt die noch
irgendwas irgendwas den ich irgendwie
treffen sollte in dem fax ja votiert
doch er wollte doch wäre der tupi paris
obtain keyboards ok perfekt aber ich
möchte einfach nur diesen man typen
mandanten antreffen der in den faqs
jahre urteilen sollte mit dem ich
irgendwie oder weil ein fax isc ihres
toxicity ich weiß aber nicht ob ich
jetzt nach links gehen soll auf die
route 2 oder ob ich jetzt wieder in
fuchsia city gehen soll oder was sich
allgemein noch machen soll die stadt sie
gleich ganz neues aus aber hat die auch
kommentierte sonne pokémon arena ich
würde trotzdem seine damen herren
beendet das video an dieser stelle ich
habe es euch geteilt hat gezeigt wenn
ihr zweites gold wo ich vielleicht man
arena kampf machen dann zeigt man mit
einer bewertung schreibt mir mal in die
kommentare wann ihr angefangen pokémon
zu spielen ob jetzt gespielt habt und
wir sehen uns dann im nächsten video
wieder ciao